en mayo los legisladores texanos
celebraron un éxito en su lucha contra
el aborto
el gobernador acababa de firmar y
convertir en ley el denominado jardín
aquí o es bien es una normativa que
prohíbe el aborto después de las seis
semanas de embarazo antes de que la
mayoría de las mujeres sepan que están
encinta lo que prácticamente ha acabado
con los abortos salvo en casos de
emergencias médicas el aborto es un
derecho constitucional en el país desde
el trascendental caso del robo contra
white en el que la corte suprema-
impidió que los estados prohibieron el
aborto en los embarazos prematuros pero
los legisladores de texas encontraron
una técnica para sacar adelante su
restricción la ley presenta un esquema
especial el estado no es quien demanda a
aquellos que ayuden a las mujeres a
poner fin a sus embarazos en lugar de
ellos son los ciudadanos particulares
sin relación con las pacientes los que
están llamados a demandar a las clínicas
por ejemplo y si tienen éxito pueden
obtener hasta diez mil dólares
texas cree que esto blinda su norma pero
las empresas que prestan los servicios
para abortar y la casa blanca quienes
demandaron la ley discrepan el
presidente ha dejado clara su postura
sobre que les vi it es abiertamente
inconstitucional no sólo viola el
derecho a un aborto legal y seguro está
bajo row contra web sino que crea un
esquema para que los ciudadanos
particulares permitan a otros ciudadanos
particulares interferir con ese derecho
y eviten una revisión judicial es por
eso que él ha ordenado una respuesta por
parte de todo el gobierno el caso es
crucial para las mujeres y puede
impactar en otros derechos
constitucionales también la estructura
especial de ese texto podría ser usado
en futuras leyes para abolir por ejemplo
el derecho a la libertad de expresión oa
poseer un arma